Hey there.
My style animal.
Hey.
Nuh, Miss Rikua.
I believe you again, ma'am. I believe when our feet of skin, feta still awaleni, in nachnan figureout el un mech sheikhil, otosketeni, il mavatlin drive.
Ida?
Can you get a screen?
I believe so
Well, the slum
Come on.
The methanol…
Milomoto.
Shabb.
And…
Take my attention.
Week 3.
into the end of email product management
Gmail product, an actual task team could
Hmm.
Must have a meeting, and then to the present to Saluro Mahaba
With discussable
Yanni,
Some have females and blue curfagame Schwat, ha.
And then I heard of the hype table on the mac
G2 to G2 products, sir.
Hmm
Baza?
G1
The label response
When I have other devices.
Oh, I know.
Hello.
So how can I
Any week when I got intent.
Allah
Every week one.
Work description
Ma'am, the…
Yes, sir Zina
planning meeting
mentioned by the end of
You make a mist.
But retro
Read through the dal kushfi in meshike…
Can you show them
El plan
What's off
And those qualitative feedback will also learn the customer
Can N2 team product management.
For the little Balfikai.
Okay.
It must match
Aman church
A rural agent review.
So, ma'am, your name as well. Can you book Ramasanan? I'll see you Michelle Zino, book Ramanad, Mahabad, Ahnatamana, para anit na kishlavadawa, had support.
And all of us
deliver the task of untuhammad
I'm a haker.
Scrum master
meaningless Chromos.
Okay.
Hajarif.
After a database
And to group two product management, Hesin
Group 1.
One only
Okay, ma'am for
Ma'am, honestly…
Meantime, we have been a scrum Master
Learner B4?
That's another, that's another…
I have an Excel sheet 2024
In meetings.
And
So I manage an otakage.
Ultra
Sir, ma'am?
Oh, I will
Do I say
Yes, also.
tasks or demi, and Red is submitted to ask Lana grab your screen.
This is my task.
Okay, Yananai, yanagte wal isny o batala soranad.
A private life group
Hello?
Okay.
Tell me
BRD.
Okay, and more of the…
Group
the
1PM to glue on file is more product requirement document.
The Mempha
Oh, I'm also…
No one group.
Agreed, agreed, and I will
human phantomot
Uh, send your task, uh, send the task.
No, thanks
Anyone?
Come out.
Okay…
Yeah, and
Come on.
I think…
Time.
The achievements, I will… achieve ryani. Malum.
Of the
Hello
If you have an announcement
I'm confused
And all…
Yeah, the new
The final presentation, but I'll feel week 4, Yan.
Hello, Samani
Hello, Samani?
You can remove the Mayan.
Okay, yes, it is relevant,
And connection with
Tabukikojiba says.
Wato?
Okay, lost… Hello.
Sir, Viji
Roboto had…
I don't want to…
And I think it wasn't forget about what Hadrutiny?
We did.
And ANE minus these combos lofijadando e uso el oat, una lavara fague.
include an original paid version?
Yes
Be honest.
Not that it's me, my mother question yet.
Hobby Valley is document mahian.
It assumes is structured.
Sarah Shukran
Computer
You don't call.
presentation individually
Sahida.
Okay.
What presentation
Tommy.
Okay, Alandoko, I'll tell you thank you so.
A notification.
Uh…
Okay, come in.
And if you have another anxiety
Hi, Shultane
Hi.
And that's fine.
Oh, yeah, tablet. Haga aweba energalu ba adequeda, koi senente kuna masuran hakken sake
We're on time
24-7.
Very funny.
The airport
Yeah, love it.
I can okay.
Rafael.
And he has
Leah, I have a lower NBG.
Hi again, it's Makar Horof.
LPRV
Are you okay?
Fire? Hmm.
Another file that's all.
Bersop.
All right.
How decades of the…
Mr. Cafei
Okay.
demand
Have to have a seat table
become…
Desktop coming
She'll take your account.
Product requirements
Okay, one email.
This one, sir?
Zip Shamani
Well.
So you can definitely runs.
type any hotel in Timu Sharpa atamin Fei.
But had an analog excel.
Okay, Kalinaro, same, Chevro has become
Online learners and accept the world optimization
Little exploration platform less features
Not yet provided, no question, deliverables, let's get content
Okay.
Shawnava was concerned about it?
URL.
Okay.
But Haga was one of my mom.
So, again, mah.
Um, Johannick.
I saw them.
How, Muhammadine, ala irkh.
Council
No, I'm a little task.
Is that the information worth it
No, not necessarily.
Any type of information, and also, yan hat kalformo, et caruchtimalihan.
What a man, you are
Alright.
Okay, I think Hanur Rotaskal Learner B5.
I mean…
Hello
Okay dokie. Hello, Stefan. I have about 21 hours
Sure.
Oh, okay
Right.
As salaam.